[Music]
this is from our friend joshua becker
over becoming a minimalist the article
is called the greatest conversation
advice i ever received i'm not going to
read the whole thing although we'll put
a link to it in the show notes i wanted
to get vanessa's thoughts on this he has
a quote in here from how to win friends
and influence people the quote is so if
you aspire to be a good
conversationalist be
an attentive listener
to be interesting
be interested
ask questions that other persons will
enjoy answering encourage them to talk
about themselves and their
accomplishments remember that the people
you are talking to
are a hundred times more interested in
themselves and their wants and problems
than they are in you and your problems
yes
yes so first let's talk about um how to
win friends and influence people for a
second if you don't mind yeah that was a
fundamental book so many people have
read it the funny thing about books like
that it's very helpful but a lot of
those books are extroverts writing about
their social skills
and that is very hard if you're not an
extrovert i'm not an extrovert i'm an
ambivert so i'm somewhere in between
if you're an extrovert writing about
communication and people skills you're
basically telling introverts i want you
to pretend to be an extrovert
right you're basically telling people i
want you to fake being outgoing and
that's going to make you likeable
and so i want to just say that yes i
love some of the principles in there but
i do not think that you have to fake
being an extrovert or fake being
outgoing to be liked
charisma is not about being extroverted
charisma about is about being interested
and that's the part of the quote that i
really like
so to be interesting you'd be interested
let's talk about let's break that down
on how that works so actually the way
that i always read that advice by the
way i remember reading that book at like
13 or 14 you know my deep awkward stage
you know hoping for something i remember
thinking what does that mean like how do
i do that so here's how you do it is
research has found that when we produce
dopamine in conversation it actually
makes you more memorable this is
research from dr john medina and what he
found is that dopamine also does a lot
of things in our body but it's it's the
chemical of motivation it's the chemical
of pleasure and excitement
and when you're asked about things that
make you feel excited you actually
produce dopamine and you create what are
called mental markers dr medina calls
them mental post-it notes that you're
with someone and they ask you a dopamine
worthy question your brain goes ooh this
person makes me feel good i'm going to
remember them
so when you produce dopamine in a
conversation people are more likely to
remember your name they're willing to
remember you so how do we produce
dopamine you literally use dopamine
triggering words such as such as so
instead of and if we can do a challenge
do not ask what do you do any more
totally agree yes when you ask someone
what do you do you're asking their brain
to stay asleep you're basically saying i
want you to stay on autopilot and answer
the same question you've answered a
thousand times before and also what do
you do is really asking what are you
worth yeah
i think it's actually a little bit of an
offensive question
so if we're going to get rid of it what
are we going to replace it with
what you want to replace it with are
things that someone defines themselves
by that get them excited so
working on anything exciting recently
that's a very very simple swap but it
allows someone to say am i working on
anything exciting and they can answer
with work or they can answer with
pleasure you can also ask
how many personal passion projects
are you looking forward to any big
projects coming up
looking forward to is a dopamine word
excited working on anything exciting is
a dopamine word have any personal
passion projects is a dopamine word so
all we're doing is we're trying to sub
out autopilot questions for dopamine
producing questions i love it so i've
turned that question around when someone
asks me what do you do yes um i'm
usually like you know uh what i love to
do
i really love to snowboard
what do you love to do yes and like that
just creates a completely different
conversation so what do you love to do
working on your personal passion
projects working on anything exciting
have any fun projects coming up there's
four that we can replace let's also
replace how are you
right yes right now every if you ask
someone how are you here's the answer
you're gonna get so how are you
busy good but busy
is that not the answer that everyone
gives every time so no more how are you
instead ask what's good um yeah but like
that simple swap asking a brain what's
good they literally are searching for
good good good good good you're
literally flipping them into gratitude
in a very simple two-word question so on
my team calls we have team calls every
tuesday i noticed at the very beginning
of a team call there was like this
awkward
oh those numbers the weather sorry i'm
late it was like it was very awkward i
was like no more so we start every team
call with tell me something good and we
all save our tell me something good of
some men mine
manager many
sort of small success that we can all
share
and
that ritual has also helped so if you
have a team call or a date or a text
thread or a friend group where you can
start to sub out but how are you how's
it been going with tell me something
good let's celebrate a win you're
literally giving people dopamine that
helps them feel more motivated
yeah i love that i got a uh we do um
minimalist.org which is like these
little meetup groups that we've set up
in some of the cities and i have a call
this saturday with all the community
leaders and i usually do like a check-in
question where i'm like you know tell me
how you're one to ten and then i'll have
a question that's going to be my
question
yeah tell me something good oh yes i
love it and i want you to pay attention
to the cues that you see
so it's funny when you ask someone an
autopilot question they stay asleep yeah
right they often have lid um
they half lid like they close their eyes
like oh god this is boring they usually
go down like they like sag their chest
down if you ask someone something good
they go up they go oh
and their eyebrows go up right when our
eyebrows go up that's universal sign of
warmth they often will go up in their
vocal power oh
because they're actually thinking and
questioning themselves they often will
sit up straighter
oh and like they pull their shoulders
back and down so even that has a
physiological change did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free